more charges against accused sexual
predator and cult leader Nathan chasing
horse 8 news now the only camera in the
courtroom today is a
today's in the criminal case against the
Dances with Wolves actor investigator
Vanessa Murphy has the very latest from
the Regional Justice Center in downtown
Las Vegas
we're learning about more
against
Norse he
grand jury on 19 charges what this means
is prosecutors presented evidence to the
grand jury during secret proceedings and
the grand jury decided he should be
charged and the criminal case against
him should move forward churches
defendant Nathan chasing horse moments
after Nathan chasing horse appeared in
North Las Vegas Justice Court here
Wednesday the grand jury indictment
announced he's charged with multiple sex
crimes 10 counts of sexual assault
against a minor under the age of 16. six
counts of sexual assault along with open
and gross lewdness first degree
kidnapping of a minor and trafficking in
a controlled substance it's really
devastating to see the amount of
exploitation that he's capable of doing
to our culture and you know how
how much trauma he's really caused a lot
of people Lakota media consultant
Allison Renville is showing her support
for the alleged victims she's a tribal
member visiting from South Dakota I
really thought it was important for me
to show up and not only offer my support
to the community here but some of the
victims that have reached out but also
to really just see the spectacle for
myself you know it's important for us to
Bear witness to these types of things
because we are the ones who are affected
the most chasing horse is expected back
in court on March 1st reporting in
downtown Las Vegas at the Regional
Justice Center Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now